[Music]
i did an audition for this
african-american black kind
either one is fine african black black
black
a black director
okay and
i i killed it in the audition okay this
is years ago uh-huh and then he goes
stick around talk
and so i and i was sat next to him
actually
and then um we were talking and then
he's like what's tell me about your
career this and that and i for some
reason we were laughing
and i poked him in the belly i go fatty
like that
is that appropriate yeah so we were like
you know he says we i don't forget what
we're laughing about we're like
and i was in the moment yeah i go fatty
like that
and i poked him really hard in the
stomach i don't know what and and he
just okay thank you
oh i mean i got that and i walked out of
the audition
and in my head i was like
but here's the thing and this is one of
the reasons why i do that a lot i know
but this is why
and i've said this before i think i said
it on this podcast last time i was here
one of my favorite things about you yeah
is that you are the same way to
everybody
that is a very
very
cool thing that most people are not and
that means that you have a solid idea of
who you are
and you're going to be you no matter
what because if you met barack obama
you'd be like
you would you would you'd be like yeah
oh the president oh
hello
that's how you do it you have a podcast
i do thank you yeah yeah i have a yeah
yeah it's called congratulations i want
to plug that all right so it's called
congratulations yes with crystal
it's just me i don't have guests i
haven't you ever had only maybe i just
said crystalia and that's all i said no
i know but maybe i'll have guests and if
i do start having guests
thank you no you know what dude exactly
thank you so much
i'm telling you because you're my
[ __ ] friend dude all right
i mean you said it like i'm doing you
throwing your line that's not what i
meant
but it probably would be good hey would
you be more asian though a mickey mouse
shirt on and no shoes um having no shoes
isn't an asian stereotype yes it is and
don't do this
when you do this that makes me nervous
don't do this okay all right
so it's not i'm gonna take my hat off
though i already know what they do all
right i already wrapped the 80s baseball
all right and i'm putting it down
there's no way i'm getting giving it to
you
that i do that make you mad like not
texting you back yeah but that's a quirk
that's just better about it since you
were on here last um
no
maybe a little bit yeah yeah maybe a
little bit i mean you do call me out on
it yeah in public yup in front of other
people yeah because i don't want them to
feel bad that you're not texting them
back right i want to be like listen he
does it to me too and i'm on his f
the thing is is that when you tell other
people yeah they he like i have like
you know people that are below not below
but in career-wise
worms yeah or the worms right yeah go
ahead i texted you about doing you know
my belly room show right right right and
i go yeah but i just don't text back and
then you'll come in and go he doesn't
take anybody back yeah yeah yeah who you
are yeah right it's annoying as [ __ ]
it's annoying yeah and barack obama be
like why don't you text me back and
you'll be like fatty
so let me get this straight kalila
these two chinks okay well
not chinese but they're not chinese
right i think they are actually well
they were in they were in malaysia so it
could be anything yeah
some chinks i'm out of this
chris stop saying chinks over and over
and looking at all of us
um
these two chicks that were malaysian
mm-hmm that's how you say it by the way
in australia
i've been trying to get better about it
like
there's really no trying you just you
just [ __ ] text back dude you just see
the message and you go bootly boop boop
send that's it there's no trying okay
i'm gonna give you i'm gonna okay i'm
gonna look at my insta my my texts okay
i'm going to tell you people who like
i'll give you an example all right eric
griffin okay
he goes um
6 30 all things let me know hey [ __ ]
face wednesday 6 30
and i wait uh 24 hours right and i just
put okay
okay now when you got the text yeah when
did you get the test because
when did you
get the text
is what i'm asking and that's all i'm
asking
24 hours in advance
you got the text
hey man
when did you receive the text and then
see it
yesterday and you saw it yesterday yes
and then you think what
oh i see what you're saying
why
yeah what so here's what you think when
you i see it right this is the first
because it you know how they do three in
a row i'm getting mad
all right so he goes wednesday six three
all things all things means all things
confidence i know so he's there's
exclamation mark
when i read that at first i got nah
because he's being he's
being too aggressive wow right so i go
i'm not going to respond to that wow
right and then the second one wow let me
know are you his girlfriend
so he goes let me know okay
don't like it
because he just did our podcast last
week and he did it
he goes hey [ __ ] face wednesday 6 30.
there you go now he's getting angry
that's good so then i go okay yeah okay
so you want a guy to be
very angry at you but not aggressive
yeah yeah yeah ooh sorry crowd work is
flirting how about this though
i'm sorry
do you smell it
i hope this has a million hits
so people know you're a [ __ ] farting
barefoot farting mickey mouse wearing
yeah do i smell you're smelling no i'm
dracula
this is like one of those forensic file
type shows right i love you guys to
watch them all but so this guy was on he
had a wife he had two kids he wanted the
kids to himself and he wanted to divorce
his wife but he didn't want to have to
deal with all that [ __ ] so he wanted to
kill the wife
so he would play video games like 12
hours a day like he was like you know he
did it like you do and so he would make
friends with other people with the
[ __ ] you know on live yeah yeah so he
made friends with this one guy and
finally the wife went out of town and
he had the guy come over and they would
hang out and they were friends and they
were new you know new friends and they
were new friends for a while and he
would end up coming over every now and
then and then he talked him into he was
like we should both get the same haircut
so they went to go get the same haircut
and then he was like listen i'm going to
be out of town
um
i'm going to be out of town uh but i
want you to stay at my place and
we do and wear my clothes and everything
whatever and so the guy who [ __ ] wore
all of his clothes yeah while while the
husband went and found his wife wherever
she was and killed his wife and then
came back and then but there was video
footage of him in his clothes at his
apartment but it was the [ __ ] guy he
told to get the same haircut as himself
and oh
that's a good one right right right now
and the guy who
i think he went to jail the guy did oh
yeah because he's a [ __ ] idiot when
it comes to if you're dumb you go to
jail yeah you know what you're you're
right you know what i mean you're all
right you're right you're right not for
murder just as being an accomplishment
yeah no i don't know even if no one died
you should go to prison just for wearing
a guy's clothes and getting the haircut
haircut it's weird it's like crisco like
where you know where this wig this bruce
uh yeah yeah whatever that haircut is
yeah rick springfield rick springfield
haircut at what point wouldn't wouldn't
you be like uh yeah we could get the
same haircut i guess that's weird bro
you do it and then
the guy's like ah wear my clothes while
i'm out of town
that is the moment where i'm like
okay
you're gonna go kill someone i think
yeah
if it's business
it'll go through abby
okay so abby will go you have an
audition or they want to see you on tape
or something something something right
when he texts it's going to be like him
venting
oh yeah oh gabriel iglesias i go what
happened so and so whatever what
happened right made up you don't have i
know yeah he doesn't have a thing i'm
just giving you an example jesus christ
or like when he was he wrecked bill
cosby
do you know that
uh who's that
yeah anyway yeah but bill cosby during
the thing right
the ripen
yeah when i say the thing it's the ripen
yeah right right i get it he was just
like i don't know what to do this is
[ __ ] insane you know what i mean and
then he's a friend
i love him you don't so you don't
respond because you don't want to be
there for a friend
is it true that they have that new
russian um survival um game show where
like rape and murder is actually allowed
or is that true i mean whoa that can't
be true but that would be amazing
why
it's like some survival because
everything else is over from then on
we're done if that's real that's the
last thing and if there's a game show
where you can get a raise
yeah then that's it you're that's it
we're done as a society that's it that's
it but the russians but do i still get
in the astra if i'm raped do you still
like do i still am i in the union
and they're like you need two more
points oh you're lucky you're lucky you
almost got raped but you're not sag
eligible
yeah
yeah so russian reality tv show called
game two to allow rape and murder in
siberia oh my god oh that's i don't
believe it i don't believe that's the
guardian
yeah that's real yeah but i can't i
can't would you watch it no no a hundred
percent no no it says 2000 cameras 900
hectares
is a hectare hector hector hector
900 guys named hector
hey i'm here
[Laughter]
okay so 30 lives everything is allowed
fighting alcohol murder rape smoking
anything
they have to sign a waiver
smoking yes
but let me ask you something right now
the girls too
i think they're thirty consensus male
and
right so basically what you're saying is
is that
if there's 15 men and 15 women 15 women
are gonna get raped well there's going
to be probably a few hectares we're like
oh my ba hurts
all right he did this today at 8 45 in
the morning uh oh my god yeah
oh dude no no no no you say yeah i was
around all day
i am around
i put ian
yeah ian around you know how i do it
yeah yeah what you got to misspell [ __ ]
oh yeah yeah so show me what somebody
tell me what tell me what to say okay
you say yeah sorry
sorry s-o-r-r-y yeah sorry yeah sorry
let's misspell something i'm around i'm
around and then put now and then put a b
at the end of now around stop okay
around now
i'm around and then put a b on the back
because here's the thing
if you text back and there's a spelling
mistake it's a [ __ ] subtle way of
saying
this is my house
oh right right right i didn't check can
i add something yeah what yeah i'm
around and i'll just put a z right here
just exa and then kind of just do that
you see it let me see look yeah sorry
i'm around b and then the z let me see
it i'll show you now
there you go yeah that's a good one i'm
around
and then can i put some sort of like
like a hashtag
yeah yeah like you're on the treadmill
yeah on the treadmill yeah sorry
yeah it's better when you when it seems
like you're just kind of like you're
like oh i put a b in there [ __ ] it sent
that i didn't check it you know what i
mean yeah you're on the move can i also
say something about elsa but but my rule
is
but my rules oh [ __ ] this is my bad
picture we're going back to the [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah
if i'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it okay now if you leave your
phone out unattended with no code on it
yeah and you look the other way and i
got a spot to have a [ __ ] silly goose
time
if there's a [ __ ]
a moment in time where i could take this
[ __ ] time from a regular time and
[ __ ] raise it up to a silly goose
time
i'm gonna grab your phone and tweet out
some [ __ ] yeah
and do you know why why because that's
your ass you [ __ ] left the phone out
right you left the phone out now if i
know the code and your phone is locked
yeah i won't do it
because you locked your phone like a
[ __ ] human is supposed to do it i am
going to tell you my code
i don't want to know the code i'm going
to tell you it anyway it's
two okay well i'll tell you this what if
you leave it locked i'm gonna leave it
locked still won't unlock it if you
leave it unlocked i'll still [ __ ]
kind of ask you something to ask you a
question okay what all right you think
when geese is hanging out yeah and
they're having a goofy time yeah they're
having a silly human time i don't know
dude
that's like some [ __ ] 90s comedy
yeah yeah this is the portion of the
show where we draw things and i feel
like you know i want to be able to draw
crystallia and i want you to draw me
oh that'll open up some like friendship
like i think it will i think it'll man
because we're fighting a lot during this
little segment and you know i kind of
want to just therapeutic this is therapy
dude all right bring it a thing
okay
so i'm gonna reveal mine uh this is mine
so these are facebook guys
the veins in his face that you can see i
put facebook guys i don't have one of my
chips that's his penis a very big penis
with the veins in the penis
okay apparently i have a heart on
because it's up right yeah and have a
penis in my chest um
this is you just chilling um
with your uh 90s underwear it says 90s
yeah and this is your hair and then the
mask what
i don't get is
that those are my eyes or those eyebrows
those are your
does your eyes and then this you were
holding the yellow so
uh i had uh you i had to do it red but
you're peeing
okay and what's that's
those are two birds
[ __ ] on your
head okay thank you and you have claws
because you can't trust you
because you know what your [ __ ]
toenails look like
you know what your thumb nails look like
they look like [ __ ] toenails okay
sean thank you
okay no i'm not gonna show them good job
are you halfway turning into a wolverine
we've run out of time man
but if there was ever a war
between you and theo vaughn yeah
if there was ever a war sure
you you have my assurance yeah this is a
slept kingdom mm-hmm
my people the papayas
will back you i like that you're the
king of the north that's very cool
you're the king of the north and my clan
and my my people
are on your team thank you [ __ ] the rat
king alas i love him as a person yeah
right i love him as a rat king but he's
the guy who gets his dick cut off in the
game of thrones
he's reek that's true right yep and then
you're jon snow right that's yeah right
and he's the one that's like he's like i
don't know what to do
my sister was captured and then you give
him like man up go get her or your
sister do what you have to do right yeah
you're that guy who are you yeah what
who are you i am uh i'm dead in it i'm
littlefinger you're a guy you're a guy
on a different show
you're inviting me wait wait
no be real yeah you're you're no no i'm
not you watch the game you watch game of
thrones you're watching that show
looking if that's your video
no but you watch game of thrones right i
saw three seasons oh you did yeah that's
what i do after that i go i'm good
i don't [ __ ] do it how everyone does
it i will not do it how everyone does it
you're gonna make me keep watching this
[ __ ] show with all the families and
[ __ ] and everyone's killing each other
and they're all friends but they're not
really friends and everyone dresses in
brown
always
yeah yeah i'm done dude where are the
dragons where are the dragons dude okay
we're the dragons when do the dragons
come in season four start
with the dragon
nope when somebody's like nah [ __ ]
building when somebody's like you got to
watch a show oh don't worry get into it
dude if i'm eating a [ __ ] burger and
and i eat a few bites and they're like
dude by the tenth bite you're rocking
with that burger you know what the [ __ ]
i know what kind of guy you are first
bite bam it's either delicious or it's
not and then there are people that want
to be like hey you know i talk about in
my act people be like hey you know i saw
my son up for soccer it's like oh my
[ __ ] god
yeah yeah oh really yeah yeah i know
dude they should make a movie about that
yeah yeah yeah come on dude yeah but see
that's you being
not a part of i dude
i know i know i'm the same [ __ ] wife
yeah i know it means like you know like
homelessness when somebody does that to
me i just want to go ding ding ding ding
ding ding
yeah yeah oh no dude but but it's funny
that i try though to participate in
those con conversations like if i'm at a
a meeting right so let's say i see you
at an a meeting hey what's up bobby hey
dude what's how was your weekend it was
pretty good how was yours what'd you do
okay uh yeah i went with my kids to the
uh mall what about you though is it good
i keep asking a question right there
yeah i like i don't know what to say so
i go is it good it explains a lot like
in conversation or when he's around my
family he leads the entire conversation
or else because he doesn't want to have
to listen to anybody else oh i do that
yeah but i do too it makes sense now
yeah bye
i want to do that
first of all that's your wallet hell
yeah dude can i see it what are you
gonna you're gonna read my [ __ ] [ __ ]
no no i just want to look okay yeah
that's your wallet yep give up give them
i gotta put it on the table because if i
sit on it i'll get scoliosis
my [ __ ] knot is too big i know yeah
if i put it in the front people are like
we're sponsored by this company yeah
dude i've seen that [ __ ] it's called
ridge wallet right yeah these are the
wallets we already i've seen that [ __ ]
theo gave me one
you're gonna give me one no i was gonna
give you one banana
i literally was gonna give you one but
not nice i gave videos away but i'll
take that one
are you gonna give it away no i'll keep
it yeah uh there he goes my flex is
called like should we should i get it
yeah as long as he doesn't say anything
incriminating okay okay
all right all right
hey matt what's up
good man what's up
what are you doing well tell them i'm
doing my podcast with crystalia right
now what's up matt
[Laughter]
wait what because i'll see you later bye
bye
it's awesome yeah because he doesn't
want to be being honest yeah who are you
i'm not what are you looking for i
literally picked up the phone yeah yeah
and he said you're texting was it
something more important no i was just
looking
for [ __ ]
the [ __ ] are you i've left
my phone in the main room true
and you've i have a rule you've but i
have a rule but now i have a code i
never should do the code but i have a
rule about it right so you used to do
instagram and twitter and like all that
stuff
yeah yeah and you know why what i guess
i have a rule
so are you around i'll tell you the
rules tell me
the rules okay
here's the here's the [ __ ] man i like to
laugh i like to have a silly goose time
i'm down for a silly goose time and
that's it dude what's a silly goose time
like a silly goose time
silly goose like we're silly goot oh
yeah yeah silly gustan
yeah yeah you don't get it cause you're
from [ __ ] north korea
they have geese there
okay yeah but hold baby but they're
saying what they're saying this is what
they're saying they don't exactly hang
out no no
hold it back okay they don't have the
saying
are you are you andrew santino right now
what do you [ __ ] mean dude because he
provokes me ethnically as well
[Music]
just the wrong way
[Music]